voilà donc des mots qui apprendront nos
enfants ce qui au début de la semaine
nous vendredi dernier sont rentrés pour
la première fois de leur vie en
maternelle alors je suis sûr que comme
moi comme de très nombreux parents vous
avez rêvé un jour d'être petit oiseau
est de voir comment votre fille votre
garçon a vécu sa première matinée de
classe bien pire champetier jacques
aubertin ont été pour vous ces petits
oiseaux n'ont pas voulu faire de
sentimentalisme leur diagnostic vous le
verrez et simplement clinique mais il
est fascinant
van leeuwen
voilà
malgré les apparences l'intégration à la
casse va se faire très vite
la maîtresse cherche à établir un
premier contact symbolique les moins
timides accepte l'engagement mais les
réticences sont nombreuses sans cri sans
larmes sept enfants s'est tout de suite
en fermé sur lui-même il faudra sans
doute plusieurs jours pour l'apprivoiser
l'attrait de la nouveauté commence à
faire son effet
plus à l'aise les petits curieux partent
à la découverte de la classe ils
prennent possession des lieux
l'unité du groupe se forme spontanément
autour des pinceaux et des couleurs
chacun apporte sa contribution à
l'oeuvre collective la classe sous
d'elle-même sans l'aide de la maîtresse
c'est gribouillis sont à l'image de la
classe qui se cherchent et se trouve la
communication s'établit par gestes cris
bruit ou regard mais deux heures a fait
la rentrée aucune parole n'a été
échangée
on sent que les dernières défenses sont
sur le point de tomber pendant la
récréation les solitaires et les timides
gravitent autour de la maîtresse
ces échanges de coups sont aussi une
façon de se mesurer et de se connaître
oui
après la récréation une nouvelle étape
est franchie on se parle leurs petits
groupes le dialogue s'instaure autour
des futurs leaders de la classe
les années passent et maman
juste avant l'arrivée des moments
l'intimité du groupe et créer la
nouvelle classe est né
excuse
donc à jouer avec les copains rien ou
droit demain